builder hi everyone I'm so so stoked to
be here thank you for having me this is
already been an awesome day and
hopefully it gets interesting now um I'm
Craig I do JavaScript at trade me in New
Zealand I work in a big angular code
base but I really like working on tools
and stuff and so this talk has come from
some things I've learnt there um we're
gonna start with the story and to make
this story happen as you need some
participation from the audience just to
shake your awake so I need everyone to
close their eyes and all together we're
gonna say the magic words
so one two three the magic words okay
great and just like that you're a wizard
this is Hagrid he's a good guy
you went to Hogwarts the school of
witchcraft in Ruby it's where all the
stuff happens in Harry Potter you can do
magic
that's a Patronus
that'll be important later you know
Dumbledore he's also a good guy and
Harry Potter is your best friend that's
Harry Potter
he's the manga guy in case you didn't
know but there's a problem
there's a snake he's a bit questionable
Voldemort is back again and he's put a
curse on Harry
and now Harry's trapped in the Internet
all right cool this is Harry and he's
trapped in the Internet if we don't save
him in the next 25 minutes Voldemort is
going to kill him
this is bad
our friend Terry is gone and time is
running out but there is a bit of good
news
Harry speaks Parseltongue he can talk to
snakes
and I'm sure as everyone here knows
Parseltongue just so happens to be a
turing-complete programming language so
I'm gonna introduce you to pass it down
assuming you don't already know it this
isn't important that it'll give you in
that area where we going so it's a
weakly typed language it's a functional
language it's an interpreted language
it's a garbage plate to the language it
has significant whitespace so I kind of
like Python or something it has some
variable declarations and so here I'm
gonna use javascript is a reference for
all of us so on the Left we have some
Parseltongue hopefully
and on the left on the right sorry we
have some JavaScript there's only one
type of verbal we don't have to worry
about anything
constantly or anything and they always
start with obviously and you notice the
assignment operator is that little arrow
with a squiggly next to it that comes
back later too there's also function
expressions again Parseltongue on the
Left JavaScript on the right you create
it with kind of an array and then a
return to the parameters they're defined
with an array and return is also just a
signing back out and you'll notice the
significant whitespace you always have
to have that and in inside your block of
your function we also have call
expressions so we can call a function
like multiply you get a product out kind
of looks how you expect
and again arguments there to clear
Berlin array so again we use the
assignment operator to pass the
arguments into the function and then to
assign the result back out to a variable
it has control flow so f is else f is
and else's which is good and it looks
like they have in JavaScript so you can
see if you haven't gotten the arguments
you function you just pass in the empty
in array head loops is a loop obviously
and the range operator is just the
assignment operator flip back the other
way
so all that comes together and allows
Harry to come up with big spells that he
writes in pass the time and on the right
you can see the equivalent JavaScript so
this is a spell that we need to help
Harry use to break out of the internet
and escape from Baltimore oh yeah also
this is oh if you can't read that if
you're at the front there's a magical
variable called cast which is just some
big global and a base if it becomes
alert you'll see why that's important
later so we're gonna check on Harry
who's just hanging out here he's go to
spell and if we run it we can't get what
we'd expect oh no something zero and
identifier is because we just dumped a
bunch of parcels hang in the browser and
expected it to do something so again
this is hairy spell it's kind of pretty
basic it assigns a variable for expecto
patronum
it makes a Patronus like we talked about
before and we're just going to loop over
a bunch of stuff and add a bunch of
exclamation marks to it so that he can
yell it more vigorously and hopefully
escape the internet but obviously
internet browsers don't understand
hassle time it's kind of the first
problem we have to face will you run it
and we just get an unexpected identifier
so we somehow need to translate Harry's
Parseltongue it's a JavaScript so we're
going to do something like this start
with Parseltongue there's something in
the middle and we're going to end up
with JavaScript so how could we try to
make this work um regex is a reasonable
solution and we saw that this morning
when passing out IDs let's have a go and
see what happens with it
so to begin with we can kind of just go
a line at a time we can pull down our
script and we can just split it on a new
line and that'll give us something like
like this not nothing too scary event if
we wanted to start looking at converting
like a variable declaration that we had
before we would just loop over each line
with the regex and try to match anything
that kind of looks like a variable
assignment and then we could just print
out the JavaScript that is equivalent to
that at the bottom that's not too bad
it's kind of a reasonable thing to do at
that point you get what you expected at
the outcome so what about what about for
loops that's pretty dark the the ridging
he gets a little bit more gnarly
you kind of look for that thing
and look for the operators and kind of
pull some stuff out and then you try to
print out some JavaScript and stuff kind
of gets a little bit weird like you have
this dangling bracket at the end kind of
don't know what blocks are or anything
like that so it's not great it's still
kind of do something with this now but
not great and kind of the same thing for
functions you can read them in run a
regex over them and you end up in a
similar situation where you've just got
this dangling dangling brace and the
rejecters are pretty horrible as well so
kind of to sum it up you don't have a
pretty bad time but we can see what that
looks like
so we run it and we kind of get some
JavaScript out it's not actual
JavaScript time and it definitely won't
run you can kind of see that if you
tried really hard you might actually end
up with something working there so we're
gonna step back just a little bit and
kind of ask a bit more of a meta
question of like what we're really
trying to do and we're trying to
transform one language into another and
this is something we already do quite a
lot like it's a self problem I don't
know if any of you use typescript or
Babel or Elm sass CoffeeScript but these
are things that we already do
transpiling is quite a specific term
it's not compiling and I asked Google
and Google said that transpiling
is taking source code written in one
language and transforming it into
another language that has a similar
level of abstraction and so if we're
thinking about Parseltongue as like
JavaScript for snakes it's kind of a
similar level of abstraction just with
some weird syntax on top of it so where
do we start let's look at some
JavaScript now and we're gonna start
looking at some of the building blocks
of JavaScript so that in the middle
there is a string literal I'm sure we
hopefully know what those are
we have identifiers we have function
calls and then the whole thing is
wrapped up in an expression and I don't
know if you noticed but I've been using
some pretty specific terms for this like
call it's pression or variable
declaration and that's because they have
meaning they're they're quite well
defined and they're well defined and
this thing called the es tree
specification it's not a real spec it's
kind of growing over the years after
someone at Mozilla whipped it up but it
kind of defines how these bits of code
are made up and so if we have this bit
of JavaScript code it can be converted
into a structure like this history is on
github you can look at some stuff with
them and then there's a tool called
esprima there are bunch of tools built
on top of the history spec you've
probably all use them but es prima is
one of my favorite it gives us the
ability to pass a string of JavaScript
code into a description of those
building blocks and that is what's known
as the AST so super easy to use just
give it a string of stuff and up pops
this AST so what is an answer it's an
abstract syntax tree this is also quite
an abstract description of what that is
so I went to Google and I looked for
cool stuff about trees which wasn't very
helpful and then I looked for cool stuff
about abstract syntax trees and I got
down to what I think is a bit more of a
understandable definition so an ast is a
data structure that represents the
structure of code without any actual
syntax so for example if you have this
bit of JavaScript and this bit of some
kind of list B language and this bit of
Parseltongue they can all be described
by the same ast which is pretty cool
so what that means think about it is
that if we can get from Parseltongue to
na st we can get from Nasty to
JavaScript so we tried this it was I
mean we could've got its work if we
really tried really hard but let's try a
new idea and see what that might look
like this is probably gonna be a couple
more steps involved here to figure them
out let's go back to esprima for just a
second so what we really want to know is
what javascript we want to end up with
at the end because then we can just
write it out ourselves in theory and so
if we just kind of pipe it into esprima
like we did before with the javascript
we can actually get out an AST
and so this prima is taking code that's
written in a specific language in this
case JavaScript and turning it into an
AST and so we need to make our own
esprima kind of thing for parcels them
so how do we do that that's a question
thankfully again it's a kind of solved
problem
yes prima does it obviously so under the
hood all passes as these things are
called doing three phases and the first
phase of this is a thing called lexing
and the end result of that is going to
be tokens so lexing or tokenizing as
it's sometimes called is the process of
breaking down source code into words
that are relevant to that language which
they're called tokens in JavaScript we
have tokens obviously so we have
identifiers and keywords and literals
and punctuate errs into file as a token
we have regular expressions and we have
templates in Parseltongue we kind of
have the same thing the only main
difference here is that because we're a
Weiss basically there be a language we
have tokens for the indentation and we
have tokens four spaces
stuff like that so for any given chunk
of Parseltongue such as this variable
declaration we would go over it
character by character and see we've got
some identified characters and then we
go to space and we've got some
punctuated characters in another space
the punctuate ER and the quote there's a
string quote the punch Raider again and
for each of those we would build up
these tokens so any if we had had
something that wasn't meant to be there
we would throw in here and so we can
apply that process to a whole passel
time spell so we can jump back over here
and see where that might look like so
kind of ran some stuff we called the
Lexx function and we ended up with a
bunch of tokens so the kind of what you
might expect if you couldn't see that
you know identify spaces and string
literals and blind terminators and add
more identifiers all this kind of stuff
so they're the chunks that make up the
things that we care about in the
language so we've already got some
tokens and now we need to get you an AST
M again after lexing most passes they
use a process which is that you're
passing step and passing is pretty
similar to mixing it's the process of
taking these lexical tokens as they're
called and applying the grammar of the
language to them so instead of going
character by character
we now go token by token and try to
build up things that actually matter to
our language so again in the case of our
variable declaration we would start with
our identifier character and go yep we
expect that and then we'd expect a space
and then that specific punctuate err so
now instead of just talking about the
idea of a punctuate ER we're talking
about specific ones we care about penis
space then a string literal and that
would give us an ast like we have on the
right hand side so you can kind of build
up that tree as you find these tokens
kind of works similarly for a function
declaration
so we have this magic function and we
have an identifier in a space then again
specific punctuate er another identifier
kind of so on and so forth to the end of
a line and then we have our indent which
tells us that we own again in a correct
amount of indentation for it to be valid
language and we use that on that block
that's really the indent to figure out
where we are for the block of this
function so the correct sequence of
tokens here would produce this following
AST the blocks comments out but
basically something like that so it's
kind of most of it we should be able to
get an AST now
so now instead of just calling Lex we're
calling Lex and then pass and we've
ended up with us here program so you can
see we've got a variable declaration
which is the string at the top then
we've got the function declaration and
then we've got our four got our four
statement which is for the loop so
that's pretty cool this is my favorite
gift for the whole slideshow I don't
know if it's from the movie but so would
that whole thing we kind of ended up
with something like this I'd only speak
to you better see it but the general
thing is that you can see this tree
structure and so there's no cycles or
anything it's just this nice tree that
goes in and then comes back out so now
we just need to get from that ast and we
need to get back to JavaScript and so
it's just cogeneration snip which kind
of sounds pretty easy um but essentially
you're really really hard and I wouldn't
really want to try to do it myself
again this is JavaScript so there's a
library for that this is a library Cody
Asche Oh Jim again really simple API
tags in an ast and produces JavaScript
at the end that's pretty cool so all of
that is working together we should be
able to get
some JavaScript and so that is the spell
that we hit before transpired in
JavaScript with the source map which you
scare for free if you use this stuff
which is pretty cool so we've got a
spell and we've kind of turned it from
past clang into JavaScript and we kind
of did a bunch of stuff so we started
with Pascal Sun and we licks it and we
got some tokens and then we pass them
and we got out an ast and then we use
ast and we generated some JavaScript and
so we're actually almost ready to save
Harry we could just run us code and it
would do everything we hope in the
browser and he'd be able get out but oh
no Voldemort can also speak past the
time got a snake for Australia good
Voldemort is gonna try and stop Harry
from escaping and he might even use the
unforgivable functions so handily for us
these happen to be global functions in
Parseltongue because that's a good
design decision and these spells are
really bad so you can like just hurt
someone or you can control their actions
or you could even kill them which is how
told them what would try to kill Harry
so we need to come up with a way to stop
Baltimore from using those functions so
we've kind of got this step in the
middle here now that we didn't expect to
have before but that's ok and we're
going to do some inspecting how about
AST so this to me is kind of the most
powerful thing about a SDS and it's kind
of the best trick of all so we can
completely transform the AST we can
validate that it looks a certain way we
can even mutate it and there are a bunch
of tools that do stuff like this already
so you got like weird pack which is just
pulling about your ASC code and wishing
it back together in different ways
you've got your saloon which is kind of
looking at stuff and validating that you
know you haven't used debugger and
production code or whatever you've got
prettier which is just like reformatting
it in a nice way and it's all because
they can kind of look at the ASC and
then do cool stuff with it and once
again there's a library for that
so yes query is another really really
great one and it gives us a bunch of
tools for querying the ast just like we
would the Dom it's on github so what we
kind of want to do is we want to learn
our code and we needed to take the bad
stuff the unforgivable functions so we
need to detect whenever Voldemort is
using one of them and then do something
reasonable so a square lets us to write
our these kind of query expressions so
here we're looking for any call
expression which is the function call
where the name of the corley the thing
that has been
old matches one of those three things
and then we're going to grab the
identifier out of that and so if we come
across any of those in a code we can
just go call the query function find any
of them and if we've got any weakness go
black now era you're not going to work
that's not going to happen but we can
actually kind of go a step further and
we can actually fix some of the stuff so
we could take those unforgivable
functions query for them and then just
replace the thing gets called with this
other spell rictusempra which is just
the tech linker which is a little bit
better so let's check that we're safe
cool so we have Voldemort's pretty good
spell I guess and we're gonna run that
oh cool so now we have the original
parcel thing at the top we have our
alerts that happened and if we run this
we should hopefully see three alerts in
a row which is pretty great
and it means the hair is a bit safer so
we started with Parseltongue we lik set
to get tokens we passed those tokens
into an AST we've been inspected those
to the AST and we modified it then we
passed the ast that the code generator
and we ended up with some JavaScript so
we are now ready and they see if they
can all work together so if we remember
from before what we expect is Harry
Potter to just scream expecto patronum a
number of times in the row with way more
exclamation marks each time if we hit
run cool so there's a debugger at the
start here because this is my final and
most amazing trick if I hit the next
thing I'm in a source map and now I'm
debugging and running Parseltongue in
the browser which is pretty funny
[Applause]
we didn't attorney and it happens a
whole bunch of times a whole bunch of
times
cool so we escaped that's great um we
did it
Harry's safe another great gift look at
these cool old as well a game with
creepy old Harry now that kind of leaves
us with a question like saving Harry
Potter is all well and good but when you
actually use these ASDs always so have
you ever had to change every file in
your Kobus like we recently upgraded
rxjs and we changed all of our files
from using their like in portable
operators to the paper ball ones and we
use the sts for that if you'd like to
generate a bunch of boilerplate code
like so if we've got a new feature that
we're spinning up we'll spin up a module
and some components and reducers and
actions and we'll build them from an ast
and just modify them to set the
particular feature we're building or
have you ever had to like extract some
information from from your code we we
pull our component library apart and we
rip out all the inputs and outputs and
the dependency structure and we do all
that with a nasty as well if you've ever
done anything like that
if you've ever passed a string you
downloaded from the internet to try to
read an ad out of it you could and
possibly should use a nasty for that
it's a bit more robust than using orig
they're really really really magical
basically they kind of help us with a
whole bunch of stuff like performance if
it's you know minification or
maintenance if it's code formatting or
you know stopping us using certain
operators or functions and their buffer
rustles that comes along with that and
the consistency you know if you've got
one format for your whole code base they
help us with analyzing our code because
we can you know pull out that API data
and my favorite thing is they help us
with a whole bunch of automation and a
bunch of really repetitive tasks
so they're everywhere
they're really powerful and they're
incredibly useful once you know how to
find them
so thanks all of this is online
you're welcome to go and look at it it's
terrible code yeah thank you very much
you